welcome to cloud security basics a
series where we explain the ins and outs
of securing your application
on google cloud sound fun then stick
around because in this episode
you'll learn about google cloud service
accounts and
why you might want to be using them
hello cloud detective last time
you foiled my plan to compromise your
company's security
but you used iam to keep your members
identity secure and keep me from
accessing the data i
wanted your employees are secure enough
but what about your scripts and
applications
if the applications that can
automatically access your resources can
be compromised then
so can a lot of your company's
information
okay so here's what we know
many times it's useful to have an
application or
script that can access resources like
data
storage buckets or other cloud resources
on your behalf without needing a person
to manually sign off
on the access one way of doing this
is by storing a user's credentials and
letting the automation script or
application use those but
there are a lot of pitfalls involved
when working with user credentials
for example if i'm using my user
credentials to access the resources in
my automation script
then anytime i share access to the
script i'll have to share my credentials
with someone else
and this opens up the possibility of
someone using my credentials
for something i didn't intend and since
i'd
also have to store my credentials
somewhere for my script to be able to
use them
this adds another security risk what if
the wrong person gets access to those
secrets
so ideally i'd like an automated way to
share access to my google cloud
resources
without having to store or share my user
account credentials
luckily google cloud provides a lot of
tools and services to protect users from
this
exact problem and in this case google
service accounts could avoid many of
these issues
for example instead of just giving out
my user credentials to run workloads on
vms
it would be better to create a service
account for the application
and grant it access to call google apis
so that users don't even need to be
involved
then i could grant groups of people
access to that service account
and this access can be easily revoked if
necessary
and doesn't involve sharing user
credentials to access a resource
but how should i set them up let's think
about this
what else do i know about using service
accounts
a service account is a robot identity
but don't tell them that and this
service account identity
is assigned to permissions and roles in
order to access resources and set
credentials
the same way you'd grant access to
humans so
because service accounts provide the
same access as user accounts
it would be wise to significantly limit
scope
and review who has account permissions
and access to your accounts on a regular
basis
service accounts don't use passwords in
the same way a user account
might so if you're within google cloud
then you can just attach service
accounts to instances and other
resources within google cloud and it'll
securely take care of authenticating the
identity of the service account
but if you're using service accounts in
another cloud platform
or on-prem you can use public and
private keys to authenticate those
service accounts
and if you're using a service key it's
important to not
download them because then you've gone
from an identity problem
which is what service accounts are
intended to solve
to a secrets management problem like
who has access to that key file and how
will that access be controlled
this is why some organizations set a
policy disabling account key creation
entirely
and if you give an individual your
service account key code
it's really not so different from giving
someone your username and password to
your account
it grants them access to whatever you
have access to
so if we decide to use keys
i want to well one
make a policy that we store them
somewhere secure and
that we don't do something like commit
the service account credentials to the
repository with the source code which
would defeat a lot of the benefits of
service accounts
two look at key rotation a security best
practice is to rotate service account
keys regularly
and this just involves creating a new
key switching apps to the new key
and then deleting the old key but it
helps a lot with securing our
credentials
as long as they're stored and accessed
securely
still that doesn't prevent the very
human errors like assigning the wrong
service accounts to the wrong users
or applications which would grant
unnecessary permissions
so to minimize the chance of that
happening
as much as possible just like with i am
it would be wise to use a naming
convention for your service accounts
it should be easy to look at a service
account and know its purpose
a naming pattern like
that could be effective here
as long as the service account name fits
into the 30 character limit
so if a cloud team requires bigquery and
cloud storage access
to automate data uploads we would
provision a service account named
that and finally
i want to implement a policy of tracking
and
logging unused service accounts so
hopefully we have some logging and
monitoring set up because a single
application can have
hundreds of service accounts if needed
and as these continue to pile up
admins may start to lose track of them
all
maybe it would be wise to create a
policy to disable service accounts that
haven't been used in a while
or at the least have someone manually
take a look at them to see if they're
still valid
that's it i think i have enough info to
set this up
egad detective i see you solved yet
another cloud security riddle of mine
i was hoping to prey on the automated
access points into your cloud
infrastructure by searching for stored
tokens
passwords and credentials and source
repos but i didn't
find any it seems like you're using
cloud
it seems like you're using google cloud
service accounts to keep your
application secure
and scalable service accounts can thwart
people like me
allow access to the right identities
when necessary and allow applications to
access gcp resources without human
intervention
they make it possible to efficiently and
quickly set up permissions scopes and
roles for your organization
to keep people like me out i hate to
admit this but you should use service
accounts if you need to authenticate
applications or scripts to use
additional google cloud
services you can use them to give out
permissions across numerous resources
without having to expose user data and
possibly negatively impact your app's
security
but you can't stop every violation from
occurring
be ready because next we'll find out
what will you do when something sneaks
past your defenses
hopefully you're monitoring and logging
what's happening in your application
or else you have no idea what to do when
something
goes wrong so there you have it
another episode of cloud security basics
next episode we'll focus on using
logging and auditing to track down
suspicious activities
so stay tuned for the rest of the cloud
security basics series
because when it comes to security you
can't let bad actors win
[Music]
you